when you do uh the movie Lincoln and
you're working with Spielberg are you
nervous in front of him when you have to
act I mean I would think it would be
somewhat unsettling a guy of that
caliber yes well uh that the
circumstances of that uh it wasn't
really nervousness as much as you're
just every part of your body is is
firing you know all Pistons are firing
because we had we had absolutely no
rehearsal none really we I I'm not
really sure I Daniel day I think maybe
Daniel liked it that way but I didn't
ask why wait we walked on the set hadn't
seen you know just sort of as character
and sat down and and cameras are ready
to go okay and it was the first scene
that you between Mary and Mr Lincoln
when you worked with Daniel Day Lewis
did he text you and as Lincoln yeah we
text we you know it's this very specific
use of of the English language at the
time so we both were we were both doing
that
of course of course but that's something
that you don't normally do as part of
the acting project oh you do oh yes it
doesn't catch my land but does it get
freaky when you're on set and the crew
has to refer to you as Mrs Lincoln no no
you don't care that's how you play it
yeah absolutely absolutely it's fabulous
and they don't care either they don't is
that a method of acting that uh who
taught you that Lee Strasbourg I did
study with Lee but certainly in trying
to stay as much in the the land that
you're portraying is is extremely
important in the in other films that
I've done that called for a very intense
three-dimensional character in Norma Ray
yes I was Norma you you threw yourself
into that role where you went to a town
you lived the life of Norman I learned
to work in the mill it was it was
fabulous when you say you learn to work
in the middle yeah you would go to the
town where Norma Ray was from well it
was the town we shot in it was the mill
we shot in so I learned to you and which
was an actual you know of
garment Mill was an actual cloth that
made fabric that's what it takes to win
an Oscar you got to put that kind of
level of commitment how long did it take
you to prepare for Norma Ray I mean when
you go and you learn the Machinery
because I would think you could kind of
fake it if you really wanted to have
some free time you don't need to go to
the town you don't need to learn how to
work it just show you the moves yeah
but not really because I mean part of
the fun of being
beings not make made the right word but
the the
Fulfillment of doing this is to
literally try to put every part of
yourself in somebody else's shoes it
changes you I mean really you don't ever
walk away the same You Come Away with a
kind of information about Humanity that
you could never have gained otherwise to
live there to sit with these people and
eat with these people and talk like them
and work beside them and try to
understand how adroit they are and using
their hands and this equipment that
ultimately ruins them or when you learn
to pick cotton how you appreciate it
rips your hands to shreds in other words
if you want authenticity in a movie
you've got to know maybe the the average
person wouldn't know how it would look
when you work machinery as Norma Ray but
there are people out there who would
know and you want to be authentic you
want to be that good